[Music]
well it's friday so we're gonna go easy
on our daily cancellation i don't mean
go easy as in be nice i definitely won't
be nice um that's one promise i can make
and always keep it's my undying pledge
but
i mean you know have a sort of an easy
subject there's a headline from the new
york post which cries out for
cancellation i think um and i need to do
very little except just sort of point in
its direction the headline how i hacked
tinder and dated 15 men in 21 days
now reading along it says
with the tinder swindler a blockbuster
success on netflix many women are wary
of matching with a man online but one
australian woman says tinder is the
perfect place to meet mr wright and is
revealing the simple hacks she uses to
maximize chances of success on the app
i'm going to stop right here there's
almost no reason to read anymore we have
all we need i guess but let me just say
at the outset
first of all that i'm already canceling
this woman and whoever wrote this
article
simply for the way they're using the
word hack
because somewhere along the line this
concept of life hacks came into
existence and now the internet is
pockmarked with 14 billion different
articles guides videos different you
know things giving advice on how to hack
various aspects of life we used to just
call this advice or tips
now it's a hack because hack sounds more
secretive and clever and edgy like it's
some sort of forbidden knowledge but
then the advice the hack is often
something incredibly basic that
everybody already knew like um
here's a life hack if you don't want to
trip while you're walking down the steps
tie your shoes or else it goes the other
way and the hack actually offers a more
complicated and inefficient way of
performing some routine task so it'll be
something like life hack
make sure you don't lose your car keys
by having them surgically attached to
your hand
so the whole
life hacking trend is stupid and it is
what i'm saying and
we could cancel just that but that's not
the primary point today in this
particular case
the life hack is a method discovered by
an australian woman for how to quote
unquote date
i think we know what she means which he
says date
15 men in less than a month
now i can already tell you how to
achieve this goal
if for some reason you want to
i'll give you the step-by-step process
for dating 15 minutes 21 days
one
be a woman
two have no moral standards
that's it those are all the steps
in fact you could probably um hack this
hack and remove the first step entirely
which you really have to seeing as how
women don't exist but really if you're
if you're any sort of person looking to
date any other sort of person
you can find an essentially unlimited
supply if you have no sorts of standards
whatsoever if you're a warm body looking
for other warm bodies
and you are unburdened by any moral
sensibilities and have no aesthetic
requirements either
the internet will provide you with all
the fodder you need
and you don't even need to be a warm
body actually pete davidson is basically
dead and look how well he's done on the
dating scene this is the world we live
in now
but then again you know i'm a married
man
i've never used tinder what do i know so
let's go back to the article and see
what tips and tricks this woman offers
i'm guessing she offers a lot of tricks
offers them turns them etc here's what
it says
helen chick who hails from sydney
says dating is simply a numbers game and
boasts that she had tinder dates with 15
different men during a recent work trip
a three week trip to new york city the
serial dater who has penned the book sex
swipes and other stories devolves how
she managed to meet so many men in such
a short period of time chick declared
that everything comes down to time and
urge tinder users not to procrastinate
while on the app she said it's important
to get small talk out of the way quickly
so that you can meet up in person as
soon as possible quote change your
location prior to arriving in the city
so you're basically matching people in a
city you're not actually physically in
but you can do all the tedious small
talk banter vibe checks et cetera before
you arrive she advised for those who are
hoping to date locally chick further
divulged her hack for cutting down on
small talk the savvy swiper said she
divides conversations into two
categories need to know and nice to know
the latter consists of light-hearted
trivial topics while the former is
focused on determining a person's morals
goals and values chick claims
conversation should be focused on the
need to know category so as to quickly
figure out whether two people are
compatible prior to putting energy into
a date
by the way um
she wants to know about your morals and
values specifically to ensure that you
like her don't have any
and and that's really her life hack she
dedicated a whole book to it
her advice um don't bother talking or
getting to know someone
just cut right to the chase get in bed
with them and move to the next one
so in other words it's exactly the two
step
two step process i mentioned at the
start be a woman
have no soul
in a pinch the first step can even be
skipped
now there's one other bit at the very
end that you'll find totally shocking it
says chick is twice divorced and she
says that that fact is a part of the
need to know category she always shares
that personal information before an
in-person meetup
twice divorced
who could have possibly predicted
twice divorced and writing a
relationship handbook
that's like me writing a book on fashion
tips
and that would be a short book also
chapter one where plaid the end now if i
may be so bold as to disagree with the
um
multiply divorced relationship guru who
collects venereal diseases like their
souvenirs
i would say that the correct approach to
dating is precisely the opposite of what
she recommends
now sure this does somewhat depend on
your goals if you're if you're an empty
miserable lonely nihilist who has
despaired of love and trust and meaning
and now wishes only to use other human
bodies like glorified masturbatory
devices
screwing the days away until you die
alone and cold with no one to mourn you
and no legacy to leave behind then
helen's method is the way to go no doubt
but if you actually want some kind of
joy and you care about things like human
dignity um
your own and other peoples and if you
want to have actual love and happiness
in your life and you want to leave this
world knowing that your time was spent
in a meaningful way and that your
progeny will live on even as you move to
the hereafter if that sounds more
appealing
then your best bet is to consider
the helens of this world and the way
they approach these things and do
exactly the opposite of what they do
you're not looking for raw numbers here
the people you're dating aren't bowling
pins that you want to simply lie down so
that you can collect the point and win
whatever game it is you think you're
playing the goal of dating is to find
one person
a person who shares your basic values
and priorities
someone who you find physically
attractive that's important also um
someone you you feel a connection with
and then once you've found that person
that that the game's over you one move
on with them and build a life together
in marriage
this means you're not looking to
get talking out of the way when you
first meet them so you can jump in bed
together jumping in bed with them
doesn't tell you anything about them
other than the fact that they're the
kind of person who does that
so actually tells you a lot which means
they probably aren't the kind of person
you want to marry but then again
you also would be the kind of person who
does that and means you're the kind of
person people shouldn't want to marry so
best to skip that step
or rather to hold off on it until the
proper time which comes within the bonds
of marriage and instead focus on getting
to know this individual and who they
actually are and what they believe
what sort of person they are
you don't need to know everything
you don't need a list of every quirk
every habit every last detail
you don't need to know things like do
they have any annoying habits they do i
can tell you that for sure
you just need to know about their moral
character can you relate to them can you
trust them
if everything lines up
you can both you know both of you can
free yourself from the clutches of the
modern dating scene which is infested
with people like helen
and move to the altar
which is supposed to be the end point of
the dating process
and you can live then maybe not happily
ever after there will still be ups and
downs bumps and potholes but certainly
you'll be living much happier than helen
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content